a town in crisis and a new costume
that's just priceless let's discuss all
the Riverdale midseason chaos together
on Sweetwater secrets High River babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and hopefully
I'm bringing you some schorl bombshell
vibes today because this is the
Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 308 chapter 43 outbreak aka our
winter finale look I even have a little
Christmas tree and everything did you
guys like this episode hit the comments
right now and stuff my stocking with
your thoughts that sounded weird today
I'll be bringing you brand new
interviews with Vanessa Morgan Cole
Sprouse and Lily Reinhart talking about
the episodes most romantic and
ridiculous moments so get excited for
that but first let's jump in and discuss
all the absolutely bonkers episode
craziness with the blue and gold
breakdown the episode started off like
the old school Riverdale we love the
Vixens
including show knee were strutting down
the hallways like the Queens they are
when all of a sudden all hell broke
loose
all the Vixens yes all of them except
for Cheryl and maa Betty started having
seizures and no one knows why
well actually Hyrum probably knows
because he was whispering to Hermione
about it when Veronica was waking up it
was in this calculation with the health
of Reggie and Cheryl Veronica piece the
puzzle together and realized that Hyrum
has been behind this whole G&G seizure
and craziness because he wants to have
control to do whatever the hell he wants
you're deluded
daddy Oberon the sisters of quiet mercy
Betty started throwing up her daily dose
of fizzle rock so her mind would stop
playing gargoyle tricks on her and she
was determined to shove Ethel into
withdrawals as well once the drug was
off in a few hours you'll see okay once
Ethel was finally free from her
hallucinations she teamed up with Betty
to capture sister Woodhouse they
uncovered that the sisters created the
gng game as a way to control the
patients and that the gargoyle king is
actually just a statue
but with visible rocks they see are
Twiggy friend he's honestly super funny
now Betty and Ethel had to trick the
patient's of quiet mercy into leaving so
they introduced a new quest and a new
Griffon Queen to leave them into the
light the king
is dead meanwhile Jughead and Archie
ended their adventures on the road with
an arrival at a junkyard complete with
the adorable jellybean debut and the
highly anticipated introduction of
Gladys Jones why didn't you call me tell
me you were coming last time I called
you you told me I couldn't come as
Jughead and Gladys tried to mend their
broken bond penny Peabody showed up
because Riverdale won't let us have a
moment of happiness and she tried to
kidnap Archie because who has it but
jellybeans saved the day drop the butter
night [ __ ] after Gladys says darkly
torturous talk with penny they realized
the best move was for Jughead to go back
to Riverdale with fp' to see what new
chaos Hiram was causing Archie decided
it was time for him to continue on his
journey alone but we got a sweet father
and son reunion with Fred and our new
dark-haired Archie wasn't truly alone he
had Vegas with him now back in Riverdale
sirens sounded and a new cliffhanger was
introduced the town of Riverdale has
been quarantined by the governor's
orders and while juggy and FP were stuck
on the outside everyone inside was
cuddling up from fear and Hiram was
reigning over his new kingdom it's so
much bigger than you giving me credit
for I honestly don't even know what to
say right now let's switch over to the
segment that always makes sense with
seven seconds in heaven so while all
that stuff was happening in Riverdale we
were treated to an emotionally charged
junkyard hug between former flames
Gladys and f.p Jones
how are we feeling about this phallus
fans tell me in the comments Veronica
and Reggie's flirty friendship continued
to grow stronger and apparently sizzle
rocks makes mevin frisky because the two
cadets were stealing kisses at school
that's talking but the biggest romance
moment that we need to discuss tonight
happened between Cheryl and Tony
that's right river babes Shoni finally
got some screen time and goodness
gracious it was worth the wait
go on while Cheryl was sweetly nursing
her fallen vixen back into tip-top shape
she took things one step further in
their relationship won't you move him
his long cuz I'm the big spoon and if
you're still freaking out over their
bedroom cuddles and I got something
that's really gonna make your Shoni
loving hearts beat even faster here's
what Vanessa Morgan had to say about
their new relationship status together
I mean I guess she's kind of like my
sugar mama she knows him sing with my
uncle and I'm you know the Trailer Park
life and she asked me to move in I think
that's a really serious step especially
in high school so I think it just shows
how in love there which is awesome well
this was originally gonna happen in
season two yes it was and then they they
cut it out how do you feel about how it
portrayed in season three and how it
played out yeah I really liked how they
they showed it in season three because
it was a cuter moment then it would have
been in season two season two it was me
arriving at her house on my motorcycle
and me being like hey babe and like I'm
moving in like with my bag of clothes
and stuff like that it was gonna be like
a really quick moment mm-hmm but now we
got you know the laying down and her
doing the official ass again this is
just super sweet so I'm happier we did
it now then right I think maybe might
have been a bit too soon because before
the road trip yeah that stuff oh I love
Vanessa and I love Shoni and I'm not
saying that Tony should have seizures
more often but I'm not not saying that
yeah they did look awfully cute together
in bed fact and now let's unleash my
ferocious and fun thoughts in hisses and
kisses
first up this one should be so obvious
but the biggest hiss of the episode goes
to all together now
Hyrum thank you to my amazing crew for
helping me out on that one I honestly
don't know what to say about Hiram
anymore you guys and let me get this
straight Hyrum you want the town to
yourself so you can let people do drugs
and Penelope blossom can run a
prostitution ring
were you not loved as a child did kids
on the playground take your toys what's
your problem dude I hate so much about
the things that you choose to be oh and
hisses - penny Peabody for trying to
make her way into all the drama on
behalf of Hiram Lodge that was so last
year in fact all of my hisses for this
episode have to do with Hiram in one way
or another hisses for making your poor
wife part of your evil plan hisses -
Penelope for being one of Hiram's hench
women and hisses - Hiram for no Josie in
this episode yeah I'm sure that's your
fault - are you angry about something
but as we switch over into kisses the
first and biggest kiss is going to the
debut of Gina Gershon as Gladys Jones
I loved how she's a fierce mama bear who
protects her cub and I loved that she
was totally happy at the prospect of
Jughead and archie being a couple
together
[Music]
you two finally got together huh Noyes
knew there was something going on
between you yes kisses to Shoney's a new
relationship status to Cheryl for not
giving any FS when her mom had a seizure
literally right in front of her and
kisses to seeing more of her oh so sweet
friendship with Veronica even when
things get particularly sticky they are
such a great combo let's do this again
kisses - seeing the heartwarming smile
on jugheads face that only jellybeans
can create I've been waiting to see
their sibling dynamic for years and my
heart felt like it was going to explode
also kisses - jelly bean for having the
confidence to hit on Archie dated as in
no longer dating I've been single get it
girl kisses - the lingering questions
between Gladys and fp2 Archie and Fred's
father-son moment and to Archie's darker
do kisses to Veronica for stepping up to
the plate as the lead detective this
week and to the fact that we finally got
our phone call between our B and V
besties we all thought you were at the
farm and so so many kisses to Betty for
saving herself from the sisters of quiet
mercy oh and for being the Griffon Queen
that I never knew I needed but now I
can't live without did you love that
outfit yeah me too so here's what Lilly
and Cole had to say about Betty's new
DIY love hello my Griffin Queen yes yeah
that was fun Park there she be talk to
me about the first time you put on that
costume okay so I had a specific fitting
for that outfit and you wouldn't really
think it'd be that big of a deal but I
had to wear like a harness underneath
that had these little tubes for my wings
which were handcrafted by the way all of
that was handcrafted my crown was made
out of paintbrushes very cool and you
know my mop wings it was very
uncomfortable and after we were done
with each take I got to kind of wiggle
out of it but it was fun I felt a little
ridiculous also kind of majestic but
mostly ridiculous please tell me you've
seen this
of Lily as the Griffon Queen I have not
she didn't want to show me the outfit
either I think I kept it a secret from
everyone I wanted to be a grand reveal
because I have this woman where I step
into the light and it's like there's
like smoke really cool fan on medium
like oh jeez it's really good yeah but I
also hope it's kind of cheesy like oh
yeah yeah that's pretty sure it's like a
bomb yeah great oh great that's exactly
what I want it's like wow you guys
really put that together fast
congratulations
Eiffel must be very crafty you can tell
Ethel knows what she's doing I love
those two and I also love that I'll be
bringing you so many more interviews
from the entire cast once riverdale
returns from its winter break on January
16th so keep it locked to my Twitter
page over our mini hiatus because I
might be gifting you with a few early
surprises that you definitely don't want
to miss and now river babes you know
what to do give this video a like hit
subscribe and then quarantine yourself
in the comments to tell me your kisses
and kisses about episode 308 do you
understand Hiram's big plan what did you
think of Gladys and jelly bean who's
freaking out about Shoney's new status
as romantic roomies and will you be
dressing up as the Griffon Queen for
your holiday parties tell me everything
I hope you all have a wonderful holiday
season and I'll see you in a few weeks
river babes love you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]